[Music]
what are you doing [ __ ] are you doing
right now
why did you do that nobody asked you to
do that [ __ ] are you doing
I just saw through the window don't come
what the [ __ ] was that sick baby put
your headphones on yeah that was
disturbing you saw that too right it was
gross
I just saw that coming back what was
what are you doing he got excited that
music came up what this music and what
you do the DMACC shuffle how does it go
back shuffle again
donut be all soft punch it was very god
damned if I don't do that because I just
asked him before he came before you came
in I was like who's the interview that
you put up yesterday cuz I was gonna
plug that the emile hirsch interviews on
the YouTube channel weren't and I think
he got a little excited that he was
gonna get some credit for his YouTube
work and so I started doing this [ __ ]
weird dance right a d-bag shuffle well
he came up with that not me I don't care
what he came up with that's what it is
it's terrible yeah [ __ ] off exactly
it was honestly that's worse than
Travis's nano pus dance that's worse
yeah oh I like pancakes
I miss the net or push down you do I
mean I'd love to see the diner push
dance again but I don't want to see
Travis do it I honestly don't even
remember how it goes
well here's Turkey I'd like to I'd like
to play the video and then maybe we
could see if we could translate the
d-bag shuffle into the nano puss dance
yeah how's that that's fair right yeah
do the nano push dance that's right he's
getting it ready man or [ __ ] yeah I
hated the matter puss had another first
song go that of course was such a [ __ ]
jizz bag the old XM studio with the
stripper pole I was a great studio was a
great studio you didn't find it to be
too big use the strategy wall for
strippers visa for Bobo
and stuff yeah yock yock does the Niner
so you can you do that
how does have 19,000 was that an
erupting or a Travis thing it doesn't
matter it's just a name is the thing
that a puss was America
Adrian pull up the Nana puss commercial
and see if the Nana puts song is on
YouTube banana puss
you could call me the better puss oh
yeah but I remember Nana puss was it for
I was a treat right I hop oh yeah you're
right because I love pancakes
okay debaters listen to a there's no
time for a serious breakfast this
Tuesday I don't think so alright d-bag
okay so can you do the matter up was Dan
no no do it not can you you can do it
yes that's right alright and do the nano
plus before you [ __ ] in your mouth and
let me tell you something d-bag this
one's going online okay you don't eat
the mic to do the [ __ ] Nana puss are
you snapchatting it yeah I was gonna
snap chat Martin Freeman but I just
didn't that's so cool okay so you're
getting the camera ready there for
YouTube are you gonna snapchat it are
you gonna snap chat it on our account to
Adrian yeah this what do you think is
gonna go more viral our mannequin
challenge or d-bag doing the manner puss
I don't know I'd like you to I'd like to
combine your doing the nano puss with
someone playing the knockout game that's
another viral challenge wait Troy did
you just come in to watch the nadir puss
that's cool I want to you're welcome in
here anytime I just with everything
that's gone on today I'm surprised that
this is what drew you in yeah no I like
it I like it all right so you're gonna
hit play on a nanner push you know that
did you see Travis do the dance
yeah what you saw you saw you rock to it
alright you saw the video and you saw
the banana do the dance right yeah okay
yeah all right are we ready
sick bizzle sizzle Bezos obeys oh this
is obeys oh it's gonna do the nadir of
us go for
[Music]
it's great that was great
should we do another take this time you
got a look at this camera so the people
at home too for the people at home all
right you gonna you got that replay cued
up Troy good all right then let's uh
what cuz you do it [ __ ] awesome you
know why cuz you do with confidence your
confident guy you should be honestly if
I were you I'd be a lot more confident
well thinks I'm a natural Nana Pusser
cuz he's like he's like I know the guys
are kind of like you know Riven me a
little bit but the reason they they're
making fun of me is cuz I have naturally
good rhythm so yeah I like that you took
off your glasses for it to just be like
cuz yeah well he wanted to nanner push
properly yeah you wanted to be
camera-ready yeah this could be your big
break you know they all right I wouldn't
be surprised of MTV's the grind to call
you after this I think so I think so
alright for this camera now
play you know you got to play the camera
take those glasses off those beady beady
eyes of yours and yeah I'm you ready to
eat basil you gonna do it for hit for
here cuz you're not facing the camera
yeah but your your profile to it you got
a fit you don't have to be leaning on
the desk you know you can show your body
off the ladies want to hear you see your
body the female Jim Norton Sam Roberts
show fans they want to see your body
yeah singular I'm you're right there's
one lady who listens your mom alright
let's do it upsetting it's so bad he
just gets so into it I've never seen be
so into it yeah he does it with irony
and then all of a sudden a real joy
kitchen yeah it starts ironically and
then becomes joy friend right you could
talk if the intensity picks up in a
major major way you like doing that huh
that's a bit ride a you know good show
good thank you very much could that be a
fun like Friday so
operation for you may be in your
personal life yeah do the Nana puss is
Gary Busey is trying to get your
girlfriend his life you see is like his
girlfriend's on Gary's lap he's feeling
her up but he's face the other way just
not doing the dance then he turns around
and sees his girlfriend getting sexually
assaulted by Gary Busey Gary's doing the
finger push what'd you say oh wow that's
how quickly our convenient all forms of
social medias that includes Twitter huh
although even peco's right have you got
a Jim and Sam show on Twitter Instagram
stories snapchat Jim and Sam show I
think we just found this is like
American Bandstand Nana CUDA you said
Nana [ __ ] a minute ago like it was
already established that push it's slang
for vagina we got it ma'am like 10
minutes later no one is interrupting
everybody like if we're winding down
that topic of conversation it's just
like putting it out there really it's no
place for that stupid it makes no sense